oh yeah here we go oh you actually we're
I didn't even pay attention you were
able to click into the mission that's
how I don't know oh yeah now the Cabal
occupied the area and most of Mars no
one gets through their exclusion zones
okay
here we go yeah it's still kind of
nervous man all right
Oh crazy respond restricting already
right off the bat right off the bat I
just want to look at my gun real quick
if it's just blue it's a blue handgun
all right where we going
you can't even something I rides it oh
yeah because we have to go to the thing
that makes rides possible the enterprise
rent a ride Danny galley so your
enterprise have a person you've got hurt
just forgiving in their way I'm gonna go
up this spur about they're called know
maybe bridge run up this Ridge what are
we supposed to go so go down over here
where I'm going oh okay I hit a hit
invisible wall so may be playing the
ghost oh wait hang in and cannon are you
in this honker all right wait for us you
know like you guys are not going where I
just want you guys went to the up top
bunker know there's an underneath yeah
I'll shoot outside no all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna go over to the exit and
I'm gonna jump up really high you guys
can see me I think you guys passed me
I'm behind you guys they would this way
scanning for something how did I get
back on the sniper rifle now that was my
own mistake I needed a better shot gun
okay there's a thumbnail here I'm gonna
wait for you guys this in case they
decide to spawn monsters on me
look what come on this game I don't
think they do that in this game didn't
do this I know he was saying be careful
that whole time das is more complicated
wow thanks tinkle oh oh just opening the
doors never those guys legionary oh man
Oh fifteen this is real good this is
great whose idea was this productions
they got shield Oh
oh yeah okay I'm down wait is there a
I'm gonna yeah Oh
and these things are really coding the
face going in the face they're a hole in
the shield usually there's a hole in a
shield into the legs
well I mean while he's troubled oh okay
like 100 more
nope there's one up here on the right on
the right yeah and there's another one
on the left
all right he's dead there's another one
coming up on the right I can see him
she's ugly
good job y'all good work it wasn't so
bad
Mars Mars oh there's a ship looks good
I'm gonna go say hi guys I'm stopping
Tamaki shopping okay I know he's not
just dropping him off he's taking shots
you did not real wild card I'm coming
back I'm coming back I'm coming back I
want to see me a shot
no we are a team I want to hand said
think about his actions
Oh resist that's great that's exactly
what I want to see when I'm shooting
something
all right if you shoot them in the dome
they tend to go down ones that I just
like shot one of their heads off this is
hype this is ready
you know they're not gonna come
you have to take the fight to them now
they're coming
remember I'm shooting they'll come that
guy has a shield
Centurion here Oh
oh that guy's got a rocket launcher
that's cool or it could use some camos
use the slide baby
oh don't you dare Unreal Tournament
Salomon with that jump rocket
I'm like I am oh so bad yeah
artha all the dead deeds are out there
do we need to go hang out with them for
a little bit yeah mo I just got 100 mo
going out going out
there's one - you're right there's
definitely am out here - yeah I'm pretty
good now I think I would go back into
the bunker when you guys are done grab
em oh [ __ ] oh there's another guy here
looking one hanging on here I saw his
head of all-around vehicle link enabled
because I mean we should foolishly drive
away from this place and so it's
interesting because the music is still
like and yeah fight mode music but if
there's something in here for example
there is there's a chest
and it had ooh a green right okay
[Music]
hey scout rifle good only you where's
that chest now it's up up there it's up
on the like oh great yeah I trash a
couple of these Oh get it from down here
hey what is that this guy right it's get
rid are well it seems like the music is
done I've got so many hand cannons no
Eric
over here
you guys kind of have that Warhammer
cool like this like Space Marines giant
armor nothing not covered their brain
shoulders yeah exactly
yeah no hell mine don't get drive-by oh
I see him up there is that where we're
going
no oh good there's freaking which my
calls yeah and of course I guess I'm
right in the middle you know you should
be invulnerable while you're jumping
into special if you ask me the same
okay yeah pissed I lost my special
little doesn't take a long time to takes
a while to rev up
oh we booked it yeah we wait so we are
getting in our vehicles dress it
straight ahead there's there's a lot
more monsters though in them in the way
seriously why do you make a call I think
we're going to fight him there like
directly in front of us oh and I'm just
gonna oh okay fall off my bike well well
I don't see them anymore
watch out in front of you
there's a few right there
drop ammo
[Music]
alright I'll post ahead
I can dig it to the system to see that I
did find her okay I can dig into their
system to see what I can find him every
gate
he's gonna dig into the systems Oh
shield guys up there yeah there's two
and they're one of them turning away
I've got the attention of both of them
they went back down
breelan good point there's more guys
coming off
immune what
all right two of them are done there's
guys to the left I'm learning on a heavy
ammunition yeah
a mobile where they've got heavy ammo
too
yeah but then I gotta go get it there's
like a hundred of them down there
that's it
alright I'm out of that ammo moving up
yeah
like have their heads just like I know
it's really it's it's really rewarding
to watch somebody's head pop off
that's Raven on top of this so
apparently you can't punch through a
shield either son of a fence made oh I
can deploy the ghost here damn there's
no like territorial right no that would
be nice all right all right I didn't get
any heavy armor or heavy ammo there's
like a hole here I'm the key oh there's
a ship crap crap retreat don't get hit
by that [ __ ]
[Music]
correct
how separated Arlen oh there's a lot of
guys oh I got tossed
Oh Rebecca shit's
okay I'm pretty close to you and access
key wheel announces I'm over here all
right I'm gonna try to get you I am
runnin [ __ ] oh that's it your name
coming Oh
[Music]
the boss guy so she is on the other side
yeah he just got me
you got a charge here
[Music]
oh wait the okay oh good oh good
don't die don't die all right oh where
are you yeah oh there that was yeah
boss card game closer
[Music]
oh you're right okay that's boss guy hi
boss guy okay alright alright
there's still more to kill other than
boss guy yeah I'm killing all those
destroyers
we just dump to college one day
where the hell the divorce on me
when did I go that I was just fighting
his armors down by the way get him yeah
take a chat
yeah have you
Wow I got taken down by a just giant not
as big as it sounds I'm just on the
other platform
does giant foamy yeah and the strange
kind of sucks
try to keep your shields on but I might
essentially learn that Anna
[Music]
okay and where are you
we're shooting at me oh you're down
there I'm actually pretty close to him
thank you gonna be firing at me in a
second
that should be other shoe time hit the
foot a bit
yep can't go over it
falling down
is he charging over here yes he is
oh yeah guy when he died that's fine
sweet sweet delicious am i this guy
keeping a lit up like he's a person
I wish I'm the servant yeah I think this
way
for some reason this Mars mission is
more reasonable than that Venus really
the mobs aren't as hard
I own asleep Inc it's a gun issue like
just like I mean honestly in Borderlands
you'll have a enemy that's impossible
you have the wrong weapon yeah and it's
really possible we were fighting fire or
fire that could be
are we putting you guys all right thanks
oh we gotta get in there
all good suniye - my mistake
there's like sniping up coming from up
top to die
friggin yeah there's a shield dude in
there try and get to you
was it a bullet no I was like a turret
shot though that's pretty cool really
like one shot per side shot yeah it's
really really just pushing marks on the
other side that's why [ __ ]
oh I got hit from down there watch your
back yeah I mean there's dudes right
there its your right to is where you're
getting shot from oh there's a question
right there's a question works don't
fight that all right one right there any
one of you I don't know oh my god I
can't actually
oh yeah we're supposed to go somewhere
else anyway this is not our oh god this
isn't our desk
he was right in my face I can see you as
that fusion rifle working out no it's
better now with upgrades I'm finding it
easier to manage now that I'm used to it
I used to hate it actually so it's
actually pretty good and we need to
diversify our guns anyways so it's super
so much ego we're deploying ghosts up
here let's see what they know oh I see
are you guys doing on ammo I'm good okay
okay guys are coming [ __ ] ton of guys
are come well yeah look at that
whole bunch there no cover over here
nope
I got you okay oh yeah level up there's
the definition end wait did we finish
yeah no I'm just trying to kill these
guys because of her but we can looks
like try to run
[Music]